good before the actual program of the
lightning knock stocks start we're going
to give you the solution of the data
portraits and we're going to do the
raffle so thanks a lot for everybody
that participated I didn't expect for us
to to for the sheets to run out
um but they did
so
um most of you then understood this part
so the gray one the gray side was
already the solution and you had to
solve three categories
you had to solve for which better
describes the area of python
if you had to play a game would you
rather play and if you could choose one
superpower
why would you choose
now first comes the solution and then
we'll we'll see so for the first
category
the first two red and blue snakes were
the easy ones yeah so lots of people
have the blue one here and the second
one the second next one is the software
development
um then the third most popular is the
orange one
who has an orange python that can tell
me
what you have yeah tell
devops Orange
no
so don't take this way because this was
also very this happened a lot that
people didn't remember what they had
so it was a bit misleading so that I
meant the bottom one
does somebody have the orange mouth yeah
web development yeah so orange was web
development
then the next one was the yellow one
devops yeah somebody said okay
and then the the next ones were a bit
more tricky the Lila the Lila one
somebody have the Lila one yeah
Community those was already difficult to
find
then we had the the Navy
the Navy one
somebody with navy
I don't see
anybody okay so it was governance
and then we had the green one the green
python we have one with the green python
well it's the one that's left so
security
and those ones were really really really
difficult to find if you have here
distribution so we have almost half is
is data but we only have four four
security
and seven governance yeah so
um for the other the other categories
were really
were easy everybody had them had them
correct
um
and there were like about hundreds of
missions I think and I checked and 22 22
were correct
and from this 22 we will raffle two
to give out these prices
and I will ask Alina to to choose to
choose one so I I refolded the the paper
so it's
is very fair okay
I'm really not not looking yeah just
take one
so the first prize goes to
emek
Godzilla clue
are you here
I met
Ahmed
no Emmett so shall we draw another one
yeah then okay
sorry Ahmed sorry
oh no but then you have to throw it all
right
hope we will be luckier this time so the
second chance for the first prize goes
to Christine tole
laughs
all right also not here okay so maybe
we'll keep on drawing until we find
somebody somebody around
Kristen no no okay
so one more
maybe it's not my lucky hand let me try
another one
okay Rafael ru cheva
yay
wow
so the the price is a designer notebook
and a set of their data postcards for
you to do data sketches
okay thank you very much thank you
so the second price goes to you see the
the right hand is yeah please take this
little bit better the lucky one
Lisa Marie
oh
in the same team okay
[Applause]
what a great teamwork yeah great
teamwork
okay thank you thanks for participating
we will be uploading
a a blog post also with the solutions
and have a poster so everyone can check
what they're actually put on on your
badges yeah
thanks a lot
so guys after resolving all this data
ruffle uh I did a riddle we can proceed
with lightning talks we got 11
submissions today and
it's 11.
you think so
well maybe this person will come we'll
see
yeah maybe magic will happen
so the rules are simple we have you have
five minutes for your talk and it's like
a hard stop and Sebastian will also
explain how will we indicate the end of
the talk
yeah so who knows lightning talks
who doesn't know lightning talks okay
yeah so it's it's enough so lightning
talks are very very quick talks five
minutes so I unlike maybe your CEO if
your CEO says I want to do it very quick
today
um today we really have a hard stop
after five minutes and we will indicate
this one
30 seconds before the five minutes I
will show this and you will all
uh do the same so we do a trial run so
please everyone doing this
louder a little bit
okay perfect and then after five minutes
we do a very strange thing this one
that works that works that works
okay that's it so
um but maybe you read the first one so
please welcome the first talk bar camps
and
your assistant is up first okay so so
maybe you have to talk a bit about this
yes yes so maybe while we prepare this
one
um I will uh so maybe it's a good idea
if the speakers already come near here
so are you already there so all the
speakers just be there somewhere and be
prepared
um I hope this
is quick yeah it doesn't take too long
no we don't see anything yeah I know I
have to go to the other screen first
it's already there okay okay so let me
explain uh also what we what we are
gonna do today so we just saw this this
data riddle data Maze and we will just
get some impressions of you so why you
chose some of the questions and so on so
we will do this always in between when
we have the changing of the levels
and I hope we can start with the first
one is this your first slide and this
will work okay let's give up okay it's
gonna be a short one we don't have to
time it so we'll find out
do we do we stop the time after you're
applauding him or before we applaud him
so okay give a big Applause welcome and
we start
oh thanks all right let's see if this
work hi my name is Martin and unlikely
talks you do not always show things you
always you also introduce other events
and normally you don't take the full
five minutes for those and so I'm not
going to use all of that but I would
like to invite you to two python bar
camps happening on weekends in Germany
this summer if you've never been to a
Parker a bar Camp is just like a small
conference but it does not have a fixed
schedule and it doesn't have a list of
speakers and those people who come on
the day decide what the topics what the
sessions of that day will be so who
comes to barcam will bring something an
idea something they want to talk about
and we'll find other people who want to
do the same and as these are python
themed this is really great to meet
other people who like python as well
um so the first of the two events is the
python camp and this has been going on
for 13 years it's now the 14th year it
was for a decade in Cologne then we had
to go to online for covet and we decided
we all need to have a break so this year
it is in East Germany for the first time
on Eastern Germany for the first time on
the beaches of the island of Bergen and
you can reach the event by public
transport or car and if you prefer
something more south like at least from
my point of view a month later there is
the python camp in Leipzig that's at the
last weekend of July the other one is
the last weekend of June this year
both events are supported by the python
software Bond
they target a German language audience
so the bar camps will be in German
um you can find the python software band
at the booth one floor down where you
can also ask more questions about the
markets and really be sure we target all
kinds of experience levels from
beginners to python experts you just
have to have an interest in Python and
another good thing the events are mostly
or fully paid by sponsors so they don't
cost much
for more information please visit
pythoncamp.de or come to the booth and
ask us more questions thanks
okay that's just perfect so we now we
have to wait for two minutes and 30
seconds
no so of course the next speaker can
come up and and in the meantime I'm just
interested
who is playing which games so for
example who noted down that uh yeah
board games are their favorites
oh maybe you stand up that's better for
your health
may I ask you which which games do you
like to play
sit left it's for my favorite
yeah I also like that one that's a great
one thank you so what about yours I like
crackle oh no it's not board game if I
think about it
[Music]
probably not well known yeah yeah that
sounds sounds intriguing thank you
so what about you yeah I like co-op
games because then I don't lose so I
like there's this game called paleo
which I like that's kind of new but yeah
mostly Co-op thanks we are already
finished okay bye
okay so
um uh I don't have to know what's your
name
welcome big Applause
hi everyone I'm drishti Jain uh I flew
in all the way here from India and I'd
like to present an interesting take upon
creating our own a visual world we all
are engrossed into creating the virtual
world using a number of VR applications
but one thing somewhere along the line
that maybe we tend to ignore or
something that we can focus on a little
more especially with python is to make
our product our um any kind of data that
we are working on to be more visual
uh just to kick off to tell you a little
about myself
um I come from a computer background and
I'm somebody who likes to work a lot on
Python and also share anything new that
I'm learning
um with the fellow folks in the
community I also have an initiative
called skill up with drishti that is the
QR code and you can find all details
about me there and that's my Twitter
handle so I'm pretty active there as
well
also data visualization the best way to
describe it is it is the modern
equivalent of visual communication just
like at conferences we come and we tend
to interact with folks in person that
networking has a very different impact
as compared to something that we are
doing just virtually or on Discord
Twitter LinkedIn so why not bring that
power of visual communication to our
presentations our data itself
to just kick off why it is so crucial
let's look at how we interpret data
about cyber security breaches across the
U.S
so this is the data about it giving you
a couple of seconds
so amazing right
or is it difficult to read
was it difficult to interpret right and
was there anybody who could understand
any information from this table
nobody right so that is wherein the
power of visualization comes into place
this is another representation of it
wherein the individuals affected per
state are indicated this if we spend
even a few minutes say five minutes we'd
be able to interpret about it so that is
the power of data visualization it helps
us make better decisions as well as
gives us a meaningful story of the data
that we are working on
and the open source tool called orange
is very very useful for it even if you
are a beginner orange is there for you
you don't need to even know a lot of
coding in order to get started with it
it is um
a drag and drop kind of an interface so
you can add your data these are
different widgets so your file would
have all the data then you could form a
table out of it adding different widgets
to it and connecting it using lines and
it would give you a visual feel of what
would happen and you can also create
confusion Matrix you can create
different visualization plots and it is
uh component based as well as very
interactive for and intuitive for
somebody to even use it for the very
first time you'll see even Advanced
plots like Scatter Plots then you can
take decision trees you can select what
part of the decision tree that is it
that your data is working upon and
select that and work on it and also
import this you can do it through code
you can import orange as a library so if
you're deep into coding you can
incorporate it as well in your code or
if you're somebody who's just getting
started with data visualization directly
the desktop app of orange is very useful
in that case and this is the example of
classification using distribution uh
using decision trees for the data and as
you can see it is very intuitive it also
uses a lot of colors so it is also good
to learn new machine learning Concepts
and get it into practice
you can try a sellout plots box plots
heat maps and everything that you are
interested into trying even if it is a
complex machine learning concept but it
is good to have a hands-on experience
using orange and that will make it very
very easy for you to understand about it
and it provides great visualizations and
a lot of customization as well
so I would like to say go ahead make
data speak volumes and just bring out
the beauty that we see around us into
our work as well and have our data to be
more visually beautiful that's it from
my end thank you everybody
is too long right so it should be three
minutes right so maybe the next speaker
is just one minute or something no no we
keep the five minutes that's just fair
so
yeah I continue my survey
so we saw there are quite many board
gamers here what about video games
come on
whoa I didn't mention that actually I
thought it's more popular than Port
games
so what I do you like to play
I mostly play single player video games
on any console like Hogwarts Legacy
maybe heard about it remake of Resident
Evil yep that stuff okay thanks
so what about you
what's hot in The Gaming Community now
oh I don't know what's hot in The Gaming
Community but Minecraft is always hot
good good choice classic what about you
Starcraft 2. okay
so I'm going here
Elder Scrolls Oblivion
nice
so guys reveal
RPGs like Red Dead Redemption 2.
Counter-Strike
good it's all we are ready you're ready
okay
so uh a big Applause
Simone yes okay a big Applause and I
will start what where's the o'clock
no wait wait wait wait wait wait wait
we haven't practiced this thing here so
now you are you welcome him with this
perfect right and we start hello
everybody I'm simonara booty and I
represent Tech workers Coalition Berlin
here today
what is Tech workers Condition it's an
organization and it's a community of
tech workers like me and you so we are
all Tech workers trying to build
Collective power and projects that
improve our industry and our society
it's a space where Tech workers can
bring together technology workers rights
and positive social impact
we are here in Berlin but we are
throughout the world we have many
chapters in the US in Europe and one
even in India and we are a network of
chapters but we are part of a global
movement of tech workers that are trying
to reshape the tech industry to bring
democracy to our to our workplaces first
and to give more autonomy to workers but
also to address discrimination by race
gender nationality and cast and
especially to fix the damages that our
industry has done to society through the
development of harmful technology
here in Berlin we have a very a very
active chapter that meets every month
um in a general meeting that the next
one is going to be this Wednesday so you
are invited to come and here the
different groups present what they're
doing and Tech workers like you can get
involved into one of these many projects
or come with their grievances or
problems or initiatives if you want to
to organize in your own company
um we here in Berlin we cover many
topics one that is very hot these days
is mass layoffs many big companies many
startups are laying off workers here in
Berlin
um
and we are supporting workers you might
have seen some of ours outside of your
company handing out leaflets and
explaining what your rights are we
organize q and A's trainings for both
individual uh let's say action so don't
never sign what your employer gives you
always go to reunion always get
protected or Collective actions
um we organize study groups on
technology on the history of the workers
movement on what are workers rights in
Germany
and uh one of the things we are known
for here in Berlin is our network of
Works councils organizers so most of
what tech Works councils members are
part of tech workers coalition to some
degree and we help them be let's say
bring better working conditions to to
their colleagues
why should you join
first of all if you want to know other
Tech workers like you and share
experiences and have people that can
understand what you're going through if
you are being discriminated if your boss
you know is not giving you the best time
they're here like at Tech workers
commission you're gonna find people like
you second if you want to organize a
worse Council in your company we are we
can give you support we can give you
training you can meet others that went
through the same process
and also if you want to bet to build
better technology for a better Society
we do a lot we are involved in many of
these projects that are you know
software development or that analysis or
other technical projects that have a
positive impact
so follow us on our social media on
Twitter and telegram check our website
for details about the general meeting I
don't have a QR code
um old-fashioned I don't know and but
please visit the website and see you on
Wednesday come to me after after this
talk if you want to know more if you
want to get involved or start organizing
in your company I can give you some
informations or also if you are impacted
by layoffs especially in big companies
like zalando
um
thank you every everybody for listening
to me in a world that is burning taking
changing the tech industry is not only
possible but necessary together we are
stronger
[Applause]
it's really working it's actually
counting so I'm not cheating here I
forgot to say so we tried something new
this year we want to
Empower uh
non-non-government organizations
non-profits and so on so this was an
idea to to give some space in the
lightning talk so we approached some of
those organizations and this was one of
them we will have correlate tomorrow and
there's one more I think I'm lost is
there okay we will we will see it so
thank you very much for this one and
it's it's a great work you're doing
foreign
I'm interesting to understand which
superpowers people would like to gain
for example who chose to be able to talk
to animals
so please stand up
do you have a pet or why do do you want
to talk to animals no I thought it was
the best out of the list because
um it's funnier probably they have
greater details and things like that I
don't know so any
body I think raccoons would be a great
conversation partner yeah okay I think
philosophical talk would be a nice one
thank you
so do you have a pet or a favorite
animal you would like to talk to
um not really but it would be really
interesting because I mean most of them
I think something like give me food now
please food food food and yeah it's a
bit like me
okay here nice thanks anyone else yeah
uh I was actually thinking more about
wild animals like imagine traveling
somewhere in a rainforest and the
animals don't attack you but you can
talk to them and have a unique
experience so it was really the best
superpower most unique one for me
we didn't have to change anything so we
were ready from the beginning but oh
great answers interesting ideas
again let's welcome tabia wait a second
wait wait wait
so actually I take longer than all the
talks so welcome again and we go on so
before actually diving into the topic I
want to start with a question who of you
loves bread because I certainly do
quite some people fellow bread lovers
awesome
um and if you're
um so like two and a half years ago I
happened to well need something to do at
home and I thought well I do not only
love bread I'm also an engineer I want
to make a process of making my own bread
sourdough bread I was totally into it
and so yeah I got started I got some
time at hand and did my research what do
I do to actually make a successful
sourdough like a living creature in my
very own living room
um I did some research I found out that
it's actually needing some attention you
need to feed yourself though you should
name it if you do not name it it will
not survive
um spoiler did
um
what else I researched something else
and then I was like well I just get
started so I had the flour Rye flour and
I didn't need anything else just a
mortar
um did everything according to plan and
well let's say the bread that I made was
a brick
like it's it was not this fluffy
sourdough bread that you imagine it was
flat out the brick and my boyfriend
who's always very supportive was like I
think
you might do that again that's not
working out and I was very disappointed
because I made my very first bread and I
was very very proud
um
now I'm coming to the topic that I want
to talk about and that's the idea of
building one to throw it away it took me
some time to get the courage to actually
start again and not only starting again
but dealing with failing at the first
time like having something but it's
somewhat working somewhat not working
actually evaluating what I did wrong
um
spoiler two last week I've successfully
done my very first edible beautiful
looking soda bread
thank you
I also learned something very important
um
starting at some point with the
information that you have is super
necessary you will fail and if you
accept that you're going to fail and
that you need to reiterate and try and
try again it's easier to like build one
to Third Way and I think that something
software developers are pretty good at
and I want to put emphasis on it because
it also helps me in my day-to-day work I
do some research I start and then I have
something that I can evaluate and
improve and actually build software
that's fun to use in the long run
without overthinking things in the past
mainly because you can throw a result
away but you will never ever throw away
the experience that you gained building
that result and that's what I hope you
may take home with you if you did not
think about it that way
thank you
it's really great thank you
very inspiring and tasty hopefully next
time you have to bring some of the bread
maybe could it be we somehow skip Aaron
where's Aaron
in the meantime I reached the leader
group at the theater riddle of solving
competition
so what was your strategy how did you
solve it and how much time did it take
you
actually we are quite
a big group so and with different
with different interests so and
different
um backgrounds so actually we could
almost solve it with just a
yeah with just images yeah correct okay
we also talk to lots of the peoples out
there okay yeah that was the idea
so
do you need any a few more minutes again
no laptop so whoa take your time it's
interesting okay but then welcome Aaron
right wait
okay so a round of applause for Aaron
and we will start
we love a good Applause we love being
here at pycon who's excited
okay that was the very half half kind of
excitement you guys need a little more
caffeine maybe a little beer at the end
of this whatever suits your boat
um I've been working in open source
software my entire career so I've
learned a few things
as in what not to do
and here I'm going to provide some few
tips of what you probably shouldn't
follow
first off barriers
build them higher nice 10 foot tall
obstacle courses I want to see electric
shock to undershawn underground tables
and gender diversity we love it please
barriers High always please don't do
that
we love a good acronym
who knows what w
d-y-m-y-d-g-i stands for
what do you mean you don't get it
I know I know anytime you have an
acronym make sure don't explain it
definitely leave it out of your
documentation people do not want to read
that because who wants to read in the
first place why I need documentation in
the first place I saw that many of you
were mind readers actually
I know I know and
your code is the best code out there
oh yeah I heard some good affirming
yeses that's right your code is the best
out there
always be holier than thou who needs
test not me
your PR's top of the list always who
needs scrummy there just push it right
to production let's have some fun give
QA a heart attack or two
we're all working on our heart rates
this year right it's a good way to get a
workout in just push it straight to
production
new contributors no way that's cringe
you only want to invite your friends
your friends cousins and maybe your
friend's cousin's dog who knows what
kind of prayer requests they'll create
I bet they'll have some new issues I
know my dog's been begging for treats
that's how you get conclusion in open
source
and of course open source means free I
work at an open source company I don't
need a paycheck
right none of us do if we are working in
open source we all we need is some good
stars on our repos and some high fives
and someone to tell me I'm doing a good
job on Twitter every so often
bonus points of some dude preferably
straight white dude tells me my how much
their code is better than mine
love it
we love to exploit our contributors and
maintainers
the internet doesn't shut off so why
should they 24 7 work-life baby let's
keep it going
your PRS are always your highest
priority what about that Community don't
need them we've built the best code
without them
and lastly the last thing to keep in
mind as we come to the world of Open
Source is anybody can use your logo
that's right forget legal we don't need
them
definitely don't contact them once or
twice if you've ever had to deal with
marketing who needs it just let any
group use their logo terrible right
but before I leave you with this the
last thing not to do in open source is
please make sure that you don't get
involved I mean we need to make sure
that you're not thinking that open
source isn't for you wherever you're at
documentation is code and I'll leave you
with this with this well my talk may
have been ingest and had a few good
humors but seriously I do want a good
pull request obstacle course if
anybody's building that hit me up I'll
find some VC money or not
um but there is pull requests and issues
open for everybody at any skill level
documentation is contribution as well as
good handy Construction
so thank you and we'll stay for this
last like little bit because they
haven't given me the light yet we have a
talk tomorrow at 10 30 in the morning so
I hope to see you there and we'll learn
about some reinforcement learning
tomorrow morning
but thanks
so the next speaker here on the list is
Irina is that right
ah okay
can you please maybe talk slowly and
explain everything a lot
take your time with the laptop set up so
uh yeah the superpowers how about
reading Minds
anyone interested
no
you are where are you ah
so why did you choose that one
because I think it would save a lot of
time
in every aspect of life
and how will you like Channel like how
would you focus on which Minds you're
like would like to read like for example
now
would you like to read like everyone's
Minds
that is a great question I'm gonna come
back to you with that okay
you ready
yes we are ready okay then I have to
start the timer and quick Round of
Applause
foreign
hi my name is Irina and I'm one of the
developers who work on Dusk and I'm
going to try to make this a one minute
demo
because five minutes demo one minute
for the last few weeks we have been
working
um on integrating Arrow strings in Dusk
and making them easy to use and amazing
and this is how easy it is to turn on
Arrow strings in dusk right now you set
this one setting does config set data
frame converts string to true and you
magically get all your X objects D types
become Pi error strings
I already have my cluster up hopefully
hopefully I still have it up so
um I think so I'm just going to read a
data set it's about 700 million records
it's NYC taxi data set that a lot of
people work with and persisted into
memory and we'll see it should take
about
30 seconds I think
I'm running a cluster with 15 workers
here my data should already have high
rot types
okay go ahead
it's fine eyesight it's gonna take 30
seconds
okay so while it's working
um I'm going to tell you why Pi Arrow
strings are so amazing because they take
roughly maybe four times
as much space as your regular object
strings okay it's done my ID types are
here
and now I'm going to do the same thing
just with object strings
change my config setting load the same
data frame again again it has to take
about 30 seconds but this time around
this my second dashboard oh what
happened here let's refresh it
something had to break you know
okay it's working now okay uh this one
though is running on a cluster with 45
workers so if you work with dusk you
might really want to try uh turning on
Pi Arrow strings you might just take
your cluster size
and make it three times smaller and
that's all I had to show you today thank
you very much if you have any issues
with arrow strings in dusk it's
relatively new please report it to have
a pinned issue in our repository to do
that we welcome all feedback good or bad
thank you very much again
thank you
thank you very much
the next on the list would be Cornelius
but its stroke through is Cornelius here
and wants to give the talk or
tomorrow be fast your your slot was
today but no no okay you can try
tomorrow
then the next one would be Benjamin
yes so come up and uh where is Alina
yeah
and I would like to know how many of you
selected the flying abilities
so where you're going to fly
anywhere I want I mean like if you can
fly where can you not fly to like a
world out of space uh I think that
wouldn't work aerodynamically but
otherwise yeah why not well you can try
it out once right yeah but then I might
well crash
all right
anybody else who wants to fly how about
you
so basically the Instinct of wanting to
fly was born when I was watching
Inception and they talked about dreams
and how you can do basically everything
and I read into lucid dreaming and
apparently you can fly in dreams which
sounds amazing and I've managed to do
that twice but if it could be done in
real life that would be even better
let's hope for it that you can
experience the drill once
okay
thank you
yes we are ready so welcome Benjamin
with power query and a big round of
applause
hello everybody yes so it looks maybe a
little bit off topic but it's at least
on data and um
what I'm talking about
um it's a
tool by Microsoft and it's an
ETL tool you'll hear that term but we
shouldn't use acronyms so I say it's
meaning extract transform and load and
um
it can be useful if you have to connect
to various data sources and want to
transform the data in a uniform language
maybe there are other tools like that
around I would be interested
and the languages called M language
that's also on it's closed source and it
works in the editor that um
ships with this power query tool and the
tool that is Inc inserted in the MS
Microsoft tools Excel and power bi and
that is also where you load your
transformed data to in the end
I want to talk about it because I
had so much struggle with it and maybe I
can save you some
and there there is that's how it looks
so it's a low code thing you can use a
lot of
buttons that generate
code lines for you and the code lines
are always function calls it's a
functional language this m language and
you have a global scope where you can
access
um
sheet name for example is a
constant
and they call a parameter and sheet is a
query and
last call First is a function so these
three types of things you can access in
the global scope and on the right pane
you see applied steps and that is quite
nice you can look while you do your
query you can split it into single steps
and look at the intermediate results
they are kind of local scope so you
cannot access them
in other queries if I would have other
tables
like the sheet1 table here then I
couldn't access the intermediate steps
yeah so it also has code and that is
that can be accessed from this editor
and um
you can even Source control it with some
open open source initiatives and that
that here shows you also that how you
get these intermediate steps
so we started with a step Source then we
had the sheet1
sheet selection step and then I included
a temporary step
like a temporary variable and that's not
used anywhere so
um like yeah that's that's the way it's
done to to give you an opportunity to um
um to have local variables normally you
would use them but you don't have to use
them subsequently
um
so yeah I think I talked about that
already so there's Global scope and
local scope and it's a functional
language and it's very important to
remember that it's lazily evaluated
all those container types are not
computed as as a whole the tool always
just gives you a preview
about 1000 rows or something
therefore it's no problem if you have
infinite
infinite generators or something that
that they will not create
create so many
um memory entries and it's non-typed
I would say I'm at least yeah you don't
have to it's not it's like a bit like
python it's not
I call it like that in closed source so
you have to work with the documentation
but the good thing is the tool is better
than the documentation
and
um
so if you
if you are in in iterables like lists
and oh and
you have to use
um you can use Lambda functions in
iterables they call the iterables row
context and if you have and remember
it's a functional language so you have
no Loops you have to limit some stuff
thank you
very good though it takes power bi to
fill the five minutes
perfect
where are you
I'm here up there uh yeah you can
already start I try to figure out who's
the next it's the art of puzzle solving
Olga yeah okay
so I would like
like many by ladies members do we have
in the audience can you stand up
by ladies members
yay
[Applause]
I'm sorry
High distance
so from which chapter are you
um actually I was just in the meetups of
pilots and we are trying to have also a
meet up by hosting one of the meetups
and also have a presentation in paradise
and where exactly like which location
which city uh Berlin at our company Plan
D we would like to do that so I'm in
contact with privateers and we're trying
our best to do that
cool cool see you then tomorrow in the
panel session
there's another one yes I'm coming she
was very happy
so which chapter are you in
New York City wow wow that's an Applause
[Applause]
it's not very active right now but it
used to be really big yeah
nice then tomorrow we'll discuss also
more about that thank you
okay so as I said next one the art of
puzzle solving Olga stage is yours pick
Applause
all right thank you
thank you strange title for a talk right
so maybe I can refactor it into
something that's a bit more familiar to
us okay problem solving fine but this is
icon so I suppose I have to stick python
in there somehow but the truth is I
really do just want to talk about
puzzles because they're they're really
fun unfortunately when you go on Google
and you Google Search the word puzzle
and then you Google Search the word
puzzle by images you get jigsaws this
pointing right because puzzles is a lot
more than just a jigsaw puzzle and this
relationship kind of makes me sad when
people think about this when I say I do
puzzles because puzzles is really a lot
more than that and I really want to talk
about a class of puzzles called puzzle
hunt a puzzle Hunt is an event where
people usually in teams will solve a
series of puzzles you can think of it
like a virtual escape room but on
steroids
um
and uh that is because in a puzzle Hunt
is a collaborative effort and but
but puzzle it's easier for me to kind of
explain what it is right because it
still doesn't explain what it is so
imagine a crossword your favorite New
York Times crossword then imagine it
without a grid okay fine you can still
reconstruct the grid I suppose uh then
imagine a crossword and then imagine it
without Clues
uh what's going on uh so then what if
you have a circular grid what if you
have Clues replaced with Emojis or
multiple Solutions or made out of Morse
code where every answer you put a dot or
a dash in there or regular expression
Clues I think some people might hear a
lot like that
um and all of it without instruction
that tell you what to do is this even
the puzzle or is this even a crossword
um well I I will be the first to admit
this sounds a bit far-fetched but I will
also assure you that all of these exist
this is what counts as citations in our
world and all of these have been
designed very carefully to lead you to a
solution
um in the most satisfying way possible
but there's more than just crosswords
there's puzzles on wordplay or on the
Nikolai grid logic puzzles or ciphers
last year I wrote a puzzle about reverse
engineering a hash function and so you
can tell that these get very technical
using math physics that you learned and
forgot and then learned again but on the
flip side they can also have pop culture
references
and I've become a lot more proficient at
programmatically sifting through the
Pokemon database than I care to admit
so to formalize what is a hunt style
puzzle a puzzle will present you some
information in literally any form or
topic imaginable trust me and then
extract to an answer which is almost
always an English word or phrase the
commonalities you have no instructions
and that's up to you and your teammates
to find out
now this process of going from data to
solution should sound pretty familiar to
all of us so it's probably of no
surprise that a lot of puzzle Hunting
Community is dominated by people in the
tech and research industry which is why
I'm telling it to you
um so why do we do puzzles it's because
it involves some of the same lateral
thinking and problem solving problem
solving from the title talk uh that we
use in everyday life and on also on the
writing side I said I have to include
python here somehow on the writing
puzzle side it's like solving a puzzle
by itself merging web development
graphic designs data management and some
here's some repos of some of the tools
the my rate of tools have been designed
designed to run a successful puzzle hunt
uh so now I do have to do some
advertising about puzzle Hunts uh the
biggest one in our world is the MIT
mystery hunt it is teams of
um more than 200 teams up to 70 people
per team 150 puzzles or more over the
course of a single weekend and I really
encourage you to look through the
archives to see what crazy things people
have come up with to be solvable in a
competitive Manner and uh the this event
is the only one with a pride in our
world the price is to write next year's
mystery hunt
uh which me and my team can attest with
many many details
but I don't recommend starting with this
one it happens in January this year is
already over I'm thrilled about that I
have my life back and I actually
recommend starting with a more beginner
friendly hunt which is actually this
weekend the CMU puzzle hunt which is
much smaller teams but maybe you will
enjoy it I hear it's good and then the
Microsoft puzzle hunt which will be in a
few weeks
also check it out and all of these are
free to participate and you can always
find information on the puzzle hunt
calendar so with that I would like to
thank you and if you'd like to come talk
to me about how to design a crossword
without Clues I'll be more than happy to
do so thank you
foreign
there is no next speaker it's just a
title it's good news who is it
yeah yeah hello Anton so please do it
and
I think we need to include puzzle hunt
next time in our data riddle as an
option and see how big the community is
so
um yeah let's talk about the distance
that you've traveled to Berlin who we're
traveling within 500 kilometer distance
maybe we just thought so here is zero
there is oh no maybe that's okay
500 kilometer distance
more or less
well could be exact also
so where do you come from
Denmark nice how is the weather
the same is here gray
so no change for you then
all right how did you travel by train or
by by plane I must admit I took the
plane I felt bad about it but the
connection was trains is annoying we
forgive you that's that's fine
you can choose one more there's okay
there's a group over there
I hope my
my uh arm is yeah long enough
uh where I'm from is the question okay
Frankfurt
and uh how was Deutsche bun
how was deutschiban this time it was
only five minutes delayed oh that's
perfect good
you're also from Frankfurt hello I'm
from Hamburg and I'm I wasn't delayed at
all but I really have
so we wish you good luck on the your
return trip as well
okay so Anton uh we when you are no I'm
not ready
okay so big Applause for Anton good news
hi everyone and welcome to my lightning
talk that's something I always wanted to
say so thanks for the organizers for
making that happen
um this is one of the completely
off-topic talks but um Alexander
mentioned meditation I think earlier so
I think this should be okay
so who's ready for some good news we
need we all need good news right
[Applause]
so in German we have the saying the best
comes last and this used to be the last
talk but I'm just going to pretend it is
the last one and there's still one to
come it's going to be great but uh just
pretend this this would be the last one
um
I can do everything through point point
so as python developers you know this is
an ellipsis so this statement doesn't
stop actually
um who can you can you complete the
sentence in your mind if you have like a
really difficult problem what is it that
makes you able to to find a solution and
we had to Bear earlier with her bread
making experience which is which is
amazing
um but imagine imagine that she had a
master Baker at her disposal and I could
ask questions to him or imagine you are
like doing python packaging which is
really hard and maybe
um the PDF Alpha packaging like
nicobling is like sitting next to you
and you could ask him questions would be
great right or maybe you could even ask
them like what is you why is python
build like this and he will tell you
like oh back in 2000 something
yes I'm sorry I don't know the date I'm
embarrassed them
and um now there's going to be like a
plot twist maybe you didn't expect this
coming but I want to talk about
something that is
like very personal to me so please don't
um I don't mean this as this has to be
the same for everyone this is this is a
personal notion and I I have like a
favorite book and it's like really old
like
um parts of it like like 4 000 years old
I think it's called the Bible
so the Bible completes the sentence as
this I can do everything through Christ
who gives me strength
cool and
I told I totally no and I do accept that
not any but not everyone is like can say
this sentence and and also and believes
it but it's something that helps me
tremendously and that's why I wanted to
share it with you guys so maybe you
you don't know about Christ or you're
actively against Christ maybe you're
thinking like World Church has done some
Terrible Things yes it has I'm sorry for
that
um but let's uh let's um continue
because you're already here and I have
two minutes left and I would make to
like I would like to make a statement
yeah that's what it's called and
as the Bible is my favorite book I'm
gonna read you one one um one more
passage and it's this one it says God
love the people in the world so much
that he gave his only his one and only
son to save them which is like
can you can you imagine who who have you
has children
yeah me too I have like a child and he's
like um two years old and I couldn't I
couldn't imagine for my life
like um giving and giving him away and
it's not it's not
um so of course we God son is Jesus and
it's not only about that the son that
has given the way he was um yeah yeah um
you know you know the end of the story
so the the passage doesn't end here but
it continues to go on to say as a result
everyone who believes in the sun will
not die
which is kind of cool right
instead they will live forever with God
strange thing to write that uh they will
not die because because people who
believe in Christ still die right
so it's not about the death that we are
thinking of but it's like
um what happens at the end so I tease
that you and said let's go back there
the best comes last right
so
what what is last actually what happens
at the end of your life
and you all have to find your personal
answer to that question
I found mine I would be delighted if
someone makes a choice to to share um to
join me actually
I know this can be a controversial topic
so if you want to discuss find this hat
or this this like Earth hoodie and then
we will talk some more thanks
it's about crazy times because I I would
have bet 100 euros is to talk about chat
GPT but then you came up with thought
and I was like ah
[Applause]
okay so last one I we also only have a
title which is proud to be a gardener
David yes
and I'll take the like the last question
as well uh
who does prefer working on site
okay
just give me a second
so where is your office
my office is in Bonn but I actually do
not work on site all the time but only
two days a week but I that does it count
that you prefer to work on site that
yeah well my kids are going to school in
in Manheim van wertenberg so it's the
best compromise I can make to see the
team and my family yeah
and how big is the office how how big is
the team the team is seven people and I
think there's hardly a day on the week
where everybody's in but uh yeah when
that's the case I I enjoy that okay
thanks for sharing
who else
what about you how big is your office
we're about 50 people in Munich
and is it like fancy office in the
center
uh yeah it's in the center I can bike
there in 10 minutes so I'm there quite
often when my team is also there
pretty convenient yeah happy for you
and you
the biking tube office is also very
important to me
and I go a few days to office a week and
I love to have lunch with my colleagues
and talk about this and that and I can't
imagine a company that is only where I
have to work only remote
nice thanks for sharing so we uh okay
yeah we I think we are under time
pressure because I guess if it's the
correct we have to leave the building in
four minutes so
um yeah so yeah I I can already share so
please then quickly move out of the
building once it's finished
five minutes and I hope he will forgive
us
um and let's
give him a round of applause
don't read
don't read this yet first eyes on me act
like that's not there so when I thought
of this ID that I'm gonna tell you about
my life has changed and the way I look
at people the way I look at my
colleagues and mostly what my colleagues
are expecting me to tell them has
changed a lot and um well you're all
programmers you know what I mean if I
say I thought of this idea I mean I
stole it from someone I copied it and
showed it to my my friends
and it's this idea that came from our
good friend George R Martin
um American writer you might know him
from like fantasy books in the 80s and
he has the series uh called wild cards
and some people also know him from like
a small TV show called Game of Thrones
study Road and um
I'm a big fan of that
what I'm also a big fan of is what he
said here it's
um Architects and and gardeners and I
myself am a gardener and
[Music]
um
the difference is as George says now
you're allowed to look and read is
Architects will not start doing their
job until or building until the plans
are done and ready to be built
first we'll just throw some seeds on the
floor maybe plan what comes where and
then they're done and they wait until it
grows they cut here and there and in the
end they have a beautiful garden
I'm a gardener programmer so I will get
a task from my boss and I will program
it and I will see if it works as I think
a lot of people do but are afraid to
admit because we are expected to be
Architects but a lot of people here
probably don't have a background in
software development but in mathematics
economics whatever and they've never
learned the maxims of programming
um yes
um this is all fine and good and
Architects are very important they build
great products our gardeners are very
important they build interesting
products as well but they build fast
products mostly if you put them together
and an architect gets a task from a
gardener The Gardener will say just
build this I'll see each other next week
and the architect will after we come
back and be saying
it wasn't super clear to me what you
wanted and I tried to make something but
I don't know if it's correct where the
gardener you can say to give me x y and
it will be done
I notice always my colleague Daniel
sitting here in the crowd oh he's
filming hey Danielle and he comes to me
and he tells me how do you want he's a
data engineer he says how do you want
the data insert it I say
these columns are these data types make
it the polygons this data types merge
them done
I have other colleague another colleague
who our name Anonymous and he comes to
me with a question and I tell him just
do this and the next week he comes back
to me asking me again because it wasn't
super clear what he wanted even though
for me it was clear
um next time you talk to your colleagues
and give them assignments please
consider are they an architect or are
they a gardener
um and it will
um
save you a lot of trouble and extra
explanation you can also use it for the
bed
which I also like to do if your boss
ever asks you why is this product not
done you tell them yeah these these
Architects are still working on the
prototypes and if and if your boss comes
and says why is the product down you
tell him yeah I don't know it's these
it's these gardeners they in their
spaghetti clothes I don't know how to
fix their issues thank you very much
thank you
it could be if they legalize growing my
ruana next time we have to have our own
track for growing indoor Mariana okay so
you know so as I said please move out
quickly don't run but take your time but
move out quickly thank you very much and
see you tomorrow bye
[Applause]